Nathan chasing horse pleading not guilty
in court this morning this is a case
we've been following very closely which
involves allegations of long-time sexual
abuse
how do you plead to the
19 charges contained in that indictment
guilty or not this is the first time
Dances with Wolves actor Nathan chasing
horses appearing in Clark County
District Court after being indicted by a
grand jury who heard from two alleged
victims one of them saying long-term
sexual abuse began when she was underage
the other saying he sexually assaulted
her as an adult he has no guilt he has
no guilfiger no remorse no feelings
whatsoever representatives from the Las
Vegas Indian Center in the courtroom to
show support for alleged victims while
chasing horse supporters are here as
well the 46 year old is accused of
heading a cult known as the circle
claiming he's a medicine man and abusing
indigenous women and children throughout
the United States and Canada people that
I've known for years
were just you know um
poking their hooking themselves to this
guy like he was the Messiah Christopher
Boyd heads the Fort Peck Journal a
newspaper in Montana chasing horse was
banned from the Fort Peck reservation in
2015. the stories of him with underage
girls is always been you know pretty
well known as like an Open Secret you
know that uh you know a lot of places
you know you can't figure out why he was
never brought any charges or brought to
you against him sooner in January
chasing horse was arrested at his North
Las Vegas home where he lived with
several wives do you think his time has
come I hope so chasing horse remains in
custody in downtown Las Vegas while
Advocates say they're offering support
for any other potential victims we will
stand we'll stay here and we'll fight
chasing horse also invoked his right to
a speedy trial so it is scheduled for
April that is soon especially for a
complex case like this by the way the
Fort Peck reservation isn't the one
chasing horse has been banned from
he now faces federal charges along with
warrants in Montana and Canada as more
women are coming forward